what all like that you could just feel
without a cordial that's it hi guys
today is a very exciting day because we
are launching hey USA which if you don't
know is trouble serious that very night
are currently in the middle of doing I'm
Ross the United States all summer long
hence the maroon painted hotel room yeah
Marin five my fern take five babe not
flattering our travel senses have
improved but our fashion sense has done
rated it's not even close you guys one
thing we wanted to tell you since it is
premiering tonight it's kind of the
schedule that you're gonna be watching
it all summer yeah that you're not just
gonna get one big episode every week
this summer you're actually gonna get
three mini episodes on Tuesday Wednesday
and Thursday every week for the next
eight weeks and then you're gonna get
big ass episodes at the end of the
summer that you can binge watch blood
orange is the new black yeah like house
of [ __ ] whoa whoa that was very we have
a very exciting trailer for you that is
I think very much a good representation
of the tone of the show yeah he's from
the first excursion we have interest in
Alaska which you've already seen our
videos from Alaska so watch this trailer
and then go watch the very first episode
of hey USA on youtube.com slash
astronauts wanted TV here's a turn of
our show yeah I want you to do a note
and I'm gonna try to harmonize with that
ready I'm just holdin that ready
ah
to beat us up music do one more do my
way yeah hit us up on our social media
notice know where we should go what we
should do at Chris danger show rolled us
to get our drink on just realize I'm
bare chested is there anything else you
need to say about this I do one more no
I get ready
okay go baritone okay I don't know I
think this hair do they I don't know
this is all the rage in the city we're
in that we're not telling you about Oh